when the body of a man was found on a
beach in australia over 70 years ago
nobody yet
knew that the investigation that would
follow would turn it into one of the
country's greatest mysteries as even
today
we cannot say anything with certainty
about what happened on that occasion
who that man was how he ended up on that
beach
who killed him and indeed if he was even
murdered are still questions waiting for
an answer was he a spurned lover who
decided to end it all or was he actually
an international spy who was
assassinated
with inexplicable twists and turns
usually found in the pages of a good
thriller novel this investigation became
known worldwide as the mystery
of the summit of man or the tamman
should case today we'll be taking an
in-depth look at a real life whodunit
which will include untraceable poisons
hidden messages encrypted codes rare
books secret love affairs
and of course a cold-blooded murder
[Music]
it all started on the morning of
december 1st 1948
on the summerton park beach in adelaide
australia police had arrived at the
scene after receiving a call about the
body of a middle-aged man lying in the
sand
halfway propped up against a sea wall
two horseback riders were the ones who
had made the grizzly discovery at around
6am and alerted the authorities after
going in for a
closer look to make sure that the man
was indeed dead police found him to be
in his early 40s smartly dressed wearing
a clean suit and
a polished pair of nice shoes he had a
bust ticket in his pockets which had
purchased the day before
indicating that he had not been present
in somerton earlier that previous
afternoon
he also had an unused second-class
railway ticket to a nearby suburb named
henley beach
an aluminium comb a half empty pack of
chewing gum a box of matches and
strangest of all a pack of army club
brand cigarettes which
actually contained cigarettes from a
different brand called kensitus
a talk with the neighbors revealed that
they had seen a man sitting in that same
spot the night before but
they all assumed that he was either
sleeping or drunk and
left him alone one couple claimed they
saw him around 7pm while
out for a stroll and said at one point
the man extended one arm output before
letting it fall limp again afterwards he
remained perfectly still even though
there were still many mosquitoes buzzing
around his face another couple saw him
later and
while they thought it was bizarre that
the stranger was dressed in a suit at
the beach they also did not go in closer
to investigate
there were no obvious signs of ireland
so investigators initially concluded
that the man became ill
sat down and propped himself up against
the wall for a rest fell asleep or
passed out and then
died during the night it was unusual but
hardly had the markings for one of the
country's greatest mysteries
but then the autopsy happened and things
started to get weird
first pathologist john barkley bennett
concluded that the mysterious stranger
died no earlier than 2 am which means
that he was still alive when
everybody saw him the previous night
although he had been
clearly incapacitated somehow the doctor
agreed that the dead man was somewhere
between
40 and 45 years old and that there were
no signs of violence on the body
in fact he had been in great physical
condition his body was fit and his heart
was healthy even though it was heart
failure which had actually killed him
this was a bit counterintuitive to
someone who dropped dead on the beach so
the pathologist started to suspect that
foul play might have been involved
he looked for signs of poisoning and
found them the pupils were small and
unusual the spleen was around three
times the normal size
and the liver the kidneys and the
stomach were all filled with blood
moreover being poisoned would also have
explained the stranger's behavior from
the previous night where he had
seemingly been alive yet unable to move
or communicate with anyone
apart from a single arm spasm it was
starting to look like a clear
case of poisoning although whether the
man took that poison willingly or not
was still inconclusive anyway to be sure
the pathologist sent samples to a
chemistry lab to check for toxins which
they did and found nothing no cyanides
no alkaloids no phenols no barbiturates
not
a trace of any of them later during the
investigation an eminent pharmacologist
named
cedric stanton hicks indicated that a
very potent poison was likely used which
decomposed soon after his death and left
no trace
he suggested strophanthin or digitalis
although whether he was right or not
became impossible to prove in the end
even though the pathologist was
convinced that the death could not have
been natural
he could not reach a conclusion
regarding the cause of death
meanwhile the police were trying to
identify the body which the media had
taken to calling the summit a man but
little to go on there was no wallet with
the body and in fact there was no form
of identification at all
his dental records could not be matched
to any known person and
even the labels on his clothes had been
removed his fingerprints were not found
in any australian database and
even reaching out to international help
in britain and the united states yielded
no results
his photograph was circulated throughout
the entire country and even though
dozens of people came to view the body
nobody ultimately recognized him the
only minor leads that could possibly
help with identification
were a few unusual physical traits
discovered during the autopsy the summit
of man
had very smooth and soft hands showing
no signs of manual labor
but he had extremely well-developed calf
muscles the
most pronounced that the pathologist had
ever seen his toes were also
wedge-shaped indicating that the victim
wore pointed shoes with high heels
these facts together suggested that
maybe the summitted man had been
a ballet dancer or a long distance
runner
by the start of the new year the police
had exhausted all their leads and the
summit of man was still a ghost
some still argued that his death had
been a suicide but why would someone
develop such a complex method of
taking their own life and more to the
point how could they do so
they would have to first be able to get
their hands on a potent poison that
could not be traced back to them then
somehow erase all records of their
existence and make sure that nobody came
forward to identify them
in january authorities had widened their
investigation to the point where they
began examining all discarded or lost
luggage found in adelaide hotels and
railway stations
in the hopes that one of them might have
belonged to their victim it seemed
like an act of desperation but it did
produce results
on january the 14th staff from the
adelaide railway station came forward
with a suitcase that had been sitting in
their cloak room since the morning
of november the 30th the timing lined up
nicely as the previous evidence scanned
as it was also suggested that
that was the day the summit of man
arrived in adelaide but there was
nothing conclusive to connect the two
together
even so police took what they could get
the suitcase pretty much contained what
you would expect a traveling man to have
with him multiple items of clothing a
shaving kit shoe polish toothbrush
toothpaste a table knife a pair of
scissors some pencils
some handkerchiefs and a lighter the
only slightly unusual items in the
suitcase were a stenciling brush
typically used for stenciling cargo on
merchant ships and
a sewing kit containing a barber brand
orange wax thread that was not available
in australia at the time
one other small clue was the stitch work
on a coat found in the suitcase which
was unknown in australia but
was commonly used in america these signs
pointed to the possibility that the
summertime man
may have traveled to the united states
at one point or
may have even worked as a sailor like
before all labels and other identifying
markers had been painstakingly removed
from the clothing
except for three tags with the name t
keen on them this lead proved to be
another dead end though as nobody was
missing by that name in the end the
police concluded that whoever removed
all the other labels
left the ones with keen on them because
they knew it would lead nowhere
if you thought this case was confusing
up until this point don't worry
because it got a whole lot more
mysterious in june of 1949 when a new
clue
veered the investigation from unsolved
murder into spy thriller territory a new
scientist was brought in to lend his
expertise pathology professor
sir john burton in the hopes that
he might spot something that everyone
else had missed he drew a few
conclusions regarding the evidence that
had already been analyzed for example we
mentioned that the summit of man wore
nice-looking shoes but the truth is that
they were not simply
nice they were spotless and did not look
like the shoes of a man who
walked on the beach there was also no
vomit on the clothes or in the area
where the victim was found which is
unusual
seeing as the victim was poisoned this
made clelland suspect that the man had
been poisoned elsewhere and then dumped
on the beach incapacitated
but still alive in the end cleland felt
pretty confident that the summertime man
died from poison but he too admitted
defeat when it came to establishing the
cause of death
after clelland was finished with his
investigation it was time to actually
bury the victim as the body had started
to decompose
even so authorities knew they might have
been getting rid
of one of their key pieces of evidence
so they took the unusual precautions of
embalming the summit of man first then
having plaster casts made of his head
and torso
finally he was buried under concrete and
dry ground to make it easier to exhume
him should the need arise
the second more thorough examination of
the victim's clothing did yield a new
strange and unique piece of evidence
inside his trouser pocket had been sewn
a smaller fob pocket for a watch
inside that pocket was a rolled up piece
of paper with
two words printed on it tamam should in
persian
this meant finished or ended and the
murder itself often
became identified as the tamam should
case because the words were written in
such a distinctive script a
local police reporter with the adelaide
advertiser named frank kennedy
actually recognized where they came from
a book of 12th century
persian poems called the rubaiyat of
amar qiyam
the so-called astronomer poet persia you
might think that this is incredibly
obscure and archaic but the truth is
that the poems of omaki-yam were
pretty much well-known and popular in
the english-speaking world at the time
following an 1859 translation by
english writer edward fitzgerald this
new evidence made some investigators hop
on the suicide bandwagon again tamam
should were the last words in the poetry
book and the poem itself was about
living life to the fullest and having no
regrets when it was time to die
the symbolism certainly suggested a
person taking their own life
but of course it also could have easily
been staged by someone
trying to make it look like a suicide in
other words just like up until this
point
the police still knew nothing for
certain
the meaning of the words tamman should
aside police became interested in
the actual book where they came from if
they could somehow find that particular
copy maybe they could trace it back to
the source where it was bought or
borrowed from which in turn could
provide some new clues to the identity
of the person who took it they started
rummaging through all the bookshops and
libraries in adelaide and nearby towns
but struck out they then put out a
public appeal showing the distinctive
script that
the words were written in and hoped to
get lucky which
they did on july 22 1949 a man only
identified under the pseudonym ronald
francis
came forward with a copy of the rubaiyat
which he saw in the glove box of his
brother-in-law's car when he asked his
relative about it francis said that
somebody threw the book inside the car's
back seat through
an open window on november 30th while it
was parked one block away from summerton
beach
all signs pointed to this copy of the
poetry book being the one where the
scrap of paper came from and
then the police lined up the torn piece
to the page from the book
and they matched up perfectly there was
no more doubt that this was
indeed the correct copy but instead of
helping to elucidate the mystery
it made it far more bizarre for starters
this was a genuine first edition of the
english translation from 1859.
it was rare and valuable and if it
actually belonged to the summit of man
it was seemingly the only thing of value
he possessed and
yet he treated it with more disdain than
any other item casually
discarding it in a random car that he
walked by and
if he did not previously own that book
and instead obtained it just to remove
those two words and
give his death some kind of symbolic
meaning why go to the trouble of getting
such a rare copy
and how come nobody remembered selling
or blending it to him or simply having
it stolen
there was of course the other
possibility that the copy did not belong
to the summit of man
and that his killer was in fact the one
who put the torn up paper in his trouser
pocket and who also threw the book in
the back of the car of ronald francis's
brother-in-law
even so some of the same questions still
applied why use such a valuable book and
why didn't anybody report that they sold
or lost a copy what investigators
inferred was that for whatever reason
it had to be this specific edition which
the owner probably brought with them
from
someplace else so it could not be traced
the idea was given credence by two
important clues found inside the book
one was a phone number penciled on the
back cover the other clue was
markings of writing which had been
scribbled on something which had been
placed on top of the book and then
left behind faint indentations there
were five lines of seemingly random
letters of which one line
had been crossed out immediately
investigators believed they represented
some kind of secret code which could
have also potentially explained why the
book had to be the original 1859 version
the translations varied between
different editions so
if the message was hidden inside the
text of the book the code
might not have worked on any other
edition like all the other clues this
sounds plausible but can only remain
speculation because the code has never
been cracked
so what about the other leads the phone
number it was unlisted but police
tracked it down to the house of a young
woman who lived very close to summerton
beach
during the investigation her name was
kept private so she was always referred
to by the nickname
of justin or the pseudonym teresa
johnson it was only in recent years that
her true identity was disclosed with a
family's permission she was jessica
thompson
at the time a 27-year-old nurse who was
married to a man named prosper thompson
she agreed to cooperate with the
investigation as long as her name was
kept out of it
she went down to the morgue she couldn't
see the body anymore because it had been
buried but she did look at the plaster
casts taken
of his head investigators noted her
reaction as being odd as
thompson was completely taken aback and
appeared as if she was about to faint
given that she had been a nurse during
the war
thompson had surely seen a lot worse
than the plaster cast of a dead body so
unsurprisingly investigators believed
her reaction was caused by a close
connection
that she had with the deceased even so
thompson then denied knowing who he was
as far as the book was concerned she
admitted that she once had a copy which
she gave to a soldier named alfred boxel
in sydney during the war
she did not go into specifics as to the
nature of their relationship although
investigators obviously suspected a love
affair
for a brief moment police hoped that
this would finally bring the case to an
end it was a tale as old as time they
thought as
boxel was the jilted lover who decided
to take his own life after visiting the
woman he loved one last time
there was just a tiny snag in their
hypothesis however as they soon
discovered that alfred boxel was alive
and well
and working as a bus maintenance officer
in randwig not only that but he still
had his copy of the book complete with
the words tam and should
and it didn't even turn out to be the
1859 edition anyway so
well that idea went out of the window
[Music]
the dead end on the boxall theory pretty
much extinguished the last glimmer of
hope that investigators had of solving
this case
they had pursued all the leads and each
and every one of them had left the
police more confused and uncertain than
before the lack of concrete facts in
this case
led to the appearance of rumors and
hypotheses to fill the void and
one idea that still has a lot of support
is that the summit to man had been a spy
it would explain a lot of the unusual
aspects of the case the
intricate death the untraceable poison
the book and the code some people even
believe that jessica thompson had also
been a spy and this includes her own
daughter
kate in an interview kate recalled that
her mother once made a reference to
knowing exactly who the summit of man
was but
would not go into detail and on another
occasion jessica admitted to being
fluent in russian
although she again would not say when
she learned it
her family members also think it is
possible jessica was having an affair
with the summit a man and
that her son robin who was born a year
before the summertime man died was
actually his
jessica thompson passed away in 2007 so
if she did know more about the tam and
should case
while she took those secrets to her
grave but what about today
surely with modern technology and
forensics new leads could be found
while there have been a few new
developments worthy of mention the first
one was in 2011 when an adelaide woman
believed she had identified the
sommerton man as
british sailor h.c reynolds among her
father's old possessions she found the
id card of a man identified as reynolds
who
served in world war one and bore a
striking similarity to the summit a man
always 30 years younger
she took the photograph to a biological
anthropologist who compared the image to
photos of the summertime man and
concluded that the ear shape was very
similar and also found a mole which was
in the same location on both men
others disagree with this identification
claiming that they pieced together
the life of a sailor from available
records and that the real reynolds died
in 1953.
another private investigation is being
led by professor derrick abbott from the
university of adelaide who has been
researching the summit of man for over a
decade abbott and his team have
approached the case from two angles one
involves cracking the code and
the other using dna to identify the body
the first isn't going so well the team
has managed to eliminate numerous types
of ciphers but the most likely scenario
is that the code needs the original 1859
poetry book to work
which has since been lost and they have
been unable to secure another copy the
dna is showing more promise for years
abbott has been unsuccessful in his
efforts to convince the south australian
government to exhume the body of the
summit of man because
he couldn't prove a significant and
legitimate reason for it this changed in
october 2017
when he received a few hairs from the
plaster cast made of the summit a man
decades ago and was able to analyze
mitochondrial dna from that sample
abbott's latest effort swayed the
current south australian attorney
general who
approved an exclamation order late last
year obviously given the current global
situation this has been put on the back
burner but it is still possible that one
day soon we will discover his true
identity
and solve the mystery of the summit of
man so i really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe
and thank you for watching
[Music]